okay let me ask you this sorry I didn't
mean to cut you off but do you think
that as a guy anyway that you should get
into a fight in your life at some point
it depends so I used to say yes uh-huh I
don't think I wouldn't say per se that
you should get into a fight I think you
should get the [ __ ] slapped out of you
once in your life mm-hmm because it does
put in perspective that there's always
somebody bigger than you out there that
can Punk you so be careful about what
you do to somebody else so from from
that standpoint damn I think my he's on
the grapes and the stems dude they saw
the The Grapes of Wrath the adesh it was
like being outlined as [ __ ] we're gonna
have to what's it called crop this and
lift it up later damn do not leave it
alone bro let him see it man like hold
in this room dude that's just extra
small it's not like that you didn't let
me preflop first if I pull up that [ __ ]
is huge why is my pant area so tight oh
that's right so I got these these
[ __ ] compressions you just realize
yeah I just scratch my balls and I rub
my nose nice
i'ma cross my legs real quick um but
going back to it for me I think so
I think I think as a guy that you should
fight at some point in your younger life
just because you should know what it
feels like to hit somebody and to get
hit back you know and and part of that
is I guess the lesson you just brought
up is is knowing when to kind of know
your place and not get so ridiculous
right because somebody will check your
ass and beat your beat your as if if you
get out of line but another thing is
just I don't know man
I just feel like it's call most like a
rite of passage into becoming a man you
know to have been in a physical fight
and and not necessarily win right if you
win that's great too but I just don't
want my kid to be a confrontational
human being yeah yeah not like that
because I grew up way to confrontation
yeah you know I had a [ __ ] mouthpiece
on me yeah so I think arguably
a lot of the reasons why got I got into
a fight there was two factors right it
wasn't one because somebody was doing
something to a friend so out of loyalty
I just had to jump in oh yeah which was
so [ __ ] annoying because I'm like but
I have to know I I took it upon myself
like dude I I've been fighting since I
was like in first grade no joke like
physical fistfights with people since I
was in first grade I know I didn't like
it yeah no I I didn't even think about
it like dude one time I think in third
grade right
this kid kicked my friend in the balls
right for no reason but north no [ __ ]
reason right
and obviously that [ __ ] was painful and
my friend went down and he started
crying and [ __ ] and I looked at that
dude and I was like you just [ __ ]
wait you have another thing coming now
right and then um I forget it feels like
the same day or later that week I was
playing a ball in my neighborhood and
this fool made the mistake of riding his
bike down my block and I and I stopped
and I saw how old were you third grade
probably like nine what a violent little
child you when I was like you [ __ ] up
coming into my block right now and then
he was riding by I threw my basketball
at him like on his head he fell off his
bike and I got on top of him and I just
started [ __ ] going off on him [ __ ]
broke his glasses his nose is all bloody
and I started like there were cars
stopped in the middle of the street
because I was in the middle of the
street just pounding on it right one of
them was my friends uncle he got the
crazy whoopee what are you doing you
know like stop maybe about 15 minutes
later is this a white kid his parents
came to my my my house mhm
I started open the door open the door
right now
and then my mom opens the door she had
no idea she didn't know that I just did
that if this kid is sitting here face
all [ __ ] up and his your kid did this
to my son we're gonna get him expelled
from school and all this not exactly
well joke's on you my kids stupid he's
gonna get expelled either way my mom was
yeah I actually did get kicked outta
school later that year my mom was like
why did you do I think he kicked my
friend in the boss bomb went off on the
guy did you know what you're gay
exactly no so like I always you know I
had to avenge my friends man I didn't
even think twice about him like dude you
[ __ ] I I told you we talked about this
on the podcast before friends and family
men there's a line there don't cross it
with me
you know what my kid just to be a
witness just roll this [ __ ] this I do
man I saw you get beat up bro ok ok like
that I want I wanted to step in but uh
you know them cops yeah I mean I can't
do nothing that's that's what I want to
be oh I just hated that stuff too it's
because I always felt like I had to do
it and a lot of the fights that were
picked was because somebody else picked
it for me and if it was up to me I'm
most likely I wouldn't have done
anything but I was a big guy I was this
size since I was 14 yeah so you know
when you grew up full of like well you
know the area that I grew up was
predominantly black and Asian as the
Asian kid I was like the big Asian kid
in the group yes or sure so obviously
it's like okay well are you gonna go
throw down with this I'm like I guess
you know do I have to do I have to it's
I guess but a lot of the people that
were troublemakers
we're friends that I grew up with yeah I
met them later like it was likely we
wouldn't have been Frank right but
because of that loyalty that you have
growing up on the same block yeah
together you feel like you have to I
always had to pretend like I was
something that I wasn't yes I hung out
with a lot of people who weren't great
people yeah but I wasn't really them
yeah I was the anime kid and I should
have been a [ __ ] anime kid but I will
say this at all because I went through
that experience and I hung out with them
they did help me grow a [ __ ] backbone
so when people did try to Punk me it was
a very different story that's what I'm
saying
because it's for that reason that I
think that as a boy you know on your way
to becoming a man that's something you
got to go go through because if I have a
son I don't want him to be meek I don't
want him to be soft
I don't want him to like let people step
over them and stuff like that but when
you realize because I feel like a lot of
the times for people who've never been
punched in the face before that that
that's like the worst thing that can
happen in the world right like oh I
don't ever want to [ __ ] get hit but
once you take it and you get your lumps
and bruises you realize it's not that
bad you know
and it makes you feel a little bit
stronger a little bit more capable
and that's what I feel like they need to
go through that yeah it's weird too
because I think the way we grew up and
during the time that we grew up that's
just different
yeah gangster violence was very
glorified it's not now like violence is
not glorify yeah it's it's it was hyper
glorified when we grew up yeah so you
know when we when we recount these
stories some people are like oh so you
thought especially in my case oh you
thought you were a thug like no
everybody got into a fight it was just
an average yeah like there wasn't a
person who didn't get beat up yeah who
didn't get punched in the face who
didn't throw down yeah that's not to say
and that's the thing to people who say
that clearly never grew up around any
type of gangster they're a whole [ __ ]
life if you think that just because you
got into a fight suddenly you think
you're against it clearly shows that you
never grew up exactly man like getting
beat up and having like throwing fists
doesn't mean you're a tough guy it was a
way of survival kid just try to rob you
they try to beat you up yeah for any
[ __ ] reason so you had to fight back
it just happens
yes happens there's nothing to do with
trying to be a thug or a tough guy it
was just either I consistently get beat
up or I have to at least swing trying
yeah you know yeah it's just this is
what it was at the time ya know for sure
yeah and that's what I'm saying like
dude I remember first time I got jumped
second grade dude second [ __ ] great I
was fighting this kid right and then
another one of his friends came and they
joint and then they basically got me on
the ground started like punching me
kicking me whatever I remember bro I
remember this very specifically there
was this super quiet kid right I
remember his name Joe Voki shoutout to
Joe Buki if you're watching this
somewhere I probably haven't seen you in
like [ __ ] 20-some years but he
sounded like a [ __ ] yugioh card no
but this kid was like super quiet and
shy right and I think like some some
kids made fun of him because of that but
I was always cool with him I never liked
him